there are a lot of unfamiliar names on
this toyota starting lineup pittsburgh
is rebuilding they're restocking their
farm system and hopefully it's an
opportunity jeff for drew smiley to
continue it's been a very good role it's
pretty easy to me you look at that two
kind of different seasons a little bit
like max free and the fact first four
starts true could not keep the ball in
the ballpark you see the last two starts
12 innings he has been efficient expect
him to try to pound the zone tonight
against his pirates team
so now adam frazier will start it off
and that one's smacked
out to right fair ball and headed toward
the corner
frazier around first we'll dig in for
two and he's got his 14th double of the
year to start the ball game look at that
he likes hitting in this ballpark
well this guy's a doubles machine he is
a hitting machine that's already his
14th double
he's had all kinds of records
at mississippi state 27 home runs for
pittsburgh seven of them this month
and this one hammered towards center
heredia has to retreat and still
backpedaling makes the catch tagging at
second is frazier he will head to third
and it's a productive out for kevin
newman frazier 90 feet away for brian
reynolds in one hour
three balls two strikes and a floater in
for strike three couldn't pull the
trigger on a curve ball smiley picks up
the second out depth on that curveball
obviously he thought that pitch was
going to be up and out of the zone two
outs on a runner at third base drew
smiley trying to get around a lead off
double and the pitch
curveball blasted out to left and deep
ozuna back warning track and gone
jacob stallings homers
with two outs and two strikes
bringing home two runs
welcome back jacob stallings
such a big hit right there early in the
ball game you get that runner on third
with one out and you open the cash in
and it was a curveball and a hanger and
they will face will crow the former
south carolina gamecock and washington
national who's looking for his first
victory yeah it came over in the josh
bell trade
from washington it's gonna be his eighth
career start mid 90s fastball
the slider curve
change pretty good change so these
hitters will have to keep an eye on that
one-two pitch
strike three called inside corner at 96
miles an hour
and acuna is retired for the first out
here's freddie freeman freddy hitting
227 second to acuna and homer's in the
league with 12.
he paints the outside corner boy he's
dotting early back-to-back looking
strikeouts for will crow two up two down
it's pretty much the same pitch he threw
to acuna obviously cunha was batting
right-handed and it did catch the plate
stayed on the plate that one just to
touch off
smoke toward deep short nice pick up
newman sets fires throw to first it's
gonna be late
riley runs well for a big man he beats
the rap and there goes the no bid
and there's the first braves base runner
of the ball game an infield hit for
austin reilly
that's a heck of a throw for a man that
lost his footing from that far away from
first base more important the fact that
he could put it online that's one of
those you think you either pull or air
marrow
so dans be the batter 209 average for
him
and a ground ball he goes the other way
right he's going to make the turn at
second there he goes to third and dansby
swanson with a great at bat uses the big
side of the field he didn't hit that
ball hard it was a slider he had it
covered on the outer third of the plate
he didn't try to over swing first and
third one down for william contreras
currently a two-nothing pittsburgh lead
it's the one-two pitch to contreras here
it is
swing and a fly ball
to deep left at the track at the wall
it's out of here a three-run homer out
of william contreras and the braves take
a 3-2 lead on his fourth home run of the
season another homer on a two-strike
pitch this time from will crow ball a
little bit on the outer half but you see
stays through it drops a bad head on it
nice that's what i'm talking about all
of a sudden you know you need a fly ball
he tries to get the job done what
happens boom three rounds so a couple of
soft hits and a walk have the bases
loaded for the pirates and ben gamels
coming up lefty versus lefty pitch to
gamel
got him swinging strike three got him
with a curveball skipped away from
contreras about a foot he picks it up
puts his foot on the plate with the
bases loaded that secures the strikeout
so they're loaded now for freddie
freeman acuna smiley and swans in the
braves base runners 3-2 from crow
freeman swings and misses he struck him
out he went with a slider again that
time in the zone and will crow gets out
of trouble the brave strand three he's
had good numbers against lefties
reynolds nine for 23 coming in
cracks this one towards center field
sending heredia back and a line drive
splashdown
an anchor down for reynolds to tie the
game that's his fourth it is three all
he had to get it all to hit it out over
there he hit that off the end of the bat
and that sound made me think that he had
cracked his bat it wasn't all that
solidly struck i i thought but he
definitely got all of it 420 feet on
stack guys
swanson will lead it off he's two for
two tonight he's single to right he
double the left it was a hustle double
payoff pitch here it is
swung on hit deep to left headed for the
pirate bullpen gone dansby swatson have
yourself a knight here he comes
home run number six braves lead four to
three he's hitting the ball to all
fields he's making contact he's making
the opponent work and now he's making
great strides at the plate a three for
three night and that breaks the tie
that's his eighth pitch to the a b
he saw six fastballs so now all of a
sudden you've got yourself in an at-bat
don't hug him too hard pablo he's on a
roll
he had a double in the first inning he
had a single in the third inning they
got him to pop out to short in the fifth
inning
and a line drive base hit for frazier
here comes the play at the plate
he will never be in time adam frazier
his third hit the hit machine
ties the game at four we say it all the
time it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if it's a righty or lefty or if it's
hard or soft this guy just goes and
competes and he just flat out
brown trying to urge chris on here as he
readies for his 21st pitch of the inning
here it is
on the ground into the shift dansby's
got it makes the perfect throw and chris
martin strands a pirate runner and the
braves bats go to work trying to win it
at home now pittsburgh's in business
first and third nobody out and a swing
and a liner that's through a base hit
newman drives in the go ahead run
frazier up at second rbi single for
kevin newman the pirates lead five to
four in the tenth here's the o1 got a
swing and a ball hit to left at ozuna
he'll make the catch here comes newman
to the plate he will score on the sac
fly by polanco and the pirates double
their lead it's six to four two outs
braves down to their last out and it's
up to ozzy albies he's all for three
popped it up and stallings does he have
an
opportunity
raise the jolly roger he makes the catch
in foul ground then the pirates win in
10.